please leave some space to finish off
that exercise just kind of make an
estimate if you've got paper you need to
worry I'll adss you have a new piece of
paper oh we're going to look at this you
didn't look at watch me but it's just
connecting whenever you use formulas
you're going to get one of these
expressions and they'll say look X is
not just some random number I want you
to work out whether Susan tax is this
all have or whatever value of federal
substitution is about this is quickly
write a definition of the substituent
ears is when we take a credible and
become somebody's egg after right and
substitute it or a particular knowledge
you might have a word back then we first
we'll introduce the solution used when
switch swap or replace they're all fine
substitute a particular
value okay so for example let's pick out
yeah sorry that's a it's a messy and
okay start with a simple one there is
just the one kind of pro Newell here
does get repeated but there's only one
type of him so they give you a
particular value there it is and they
say he evaluate tell me how big this
whole thing is once you put in x equals
3 so all I would say is x squared minus
7x possible and I literally get a swap
every x 43 it's not rocket science but
you're just going to be careful three
gets squared then you take away 7 lots
of lost one in fact in some ways this is
easier than some of stuff we're doing
over here because the algebra kind of
goes away and just get left with numbers
now if you really want to really want to
you can go on appeal to a calculator for
that and Middle East sometimes you get
some weed value in here like something
decimal or strange strange fractions in
which case yeah there's no reason why
you don't reach me cago I think we can
do this one right pretty smeared of
course is 99 I've got to vlada Tracy
ever do expand the brackets organ just
say three plus one is four so I've got
nine feet away from you what is not a
quitter again mine is 19 negative light
that's it that's all there is to
substitution now this is not complicated
life where this does extend to just I
won't fully solving it I'll just show
you the start you can get going i
remember i said this just has the one
variable right well we've already met
questions none of which are fortunately
on the boy that have led to different
kinds of produce right like you can
obtain a B and C or r and h radius and
height any number of printing rules then
you can have particular values so as a
secondary example
okay now i'm like i said i'm not going
to show you the full ear to hear but i'm
just going to start you off looking
cover the rest of it you take your
expression whatever it may be and you
stayed it exactly as it is but with the
right terms swap information can line up
everything properly so this will become
for instance there's our so 3.2 square
times h take way through sorry to take
way through so that i wouldn't they say
to you how to do it ahead Ryan who knows
a three-point these freighters 10-point
something okay I did not have my dad ok
slightest idea um so you're going to use
can't believe that multiply it by this
is going to become 1.1 and off you go
but I open it emphasizes place please
note this okay look up for a second this
like he on this light is critical don't
go to your calculator and just punch
that in without having written this down
this shows that you know what
substitution means it demonstrates
understanding the number of the ends of
the unimportant the number at the end
your calculator can do right understand
you know how you got from this to this
to whatever know what happens to be
that's what we're really looking for
okay so please no skip that line to be
in brackets and spoke when you just
write down um so you mean we're going
from here to the meeting SI that line
over there we have a point to it
so in the next line how probably will
detract in 24 ok the reason I did that
here is because it's like three point
two squared sometimes people get what's
what exact is being square so that's
just to be clear the question you have
to put 32.2 in my ear so if you read
this I think I'm the only thing that up
yeah it is the same thing the only you
want to watch out for is sometimes like
Paris 83.2 you know that decimal point
like people actually this is really
irritating now people sometimes use that
decimal points you mean something else I
know that's that's a villain oi well for
multiplication as it happens so some
textbook shouldn't do that so if i write
this I hope it becomes clear that's
actually 3.2 it's not three and two and
some other